this episode with dr reinhard gensel uh
is one that you don't want to miss he's
a very very open vulnerable honest and
hilarious individual who was destined
perhaps if he didn't get more into
physics to become a great athlete and
even participate in the german olympic
team
in the 1960s so he would have won a
golden medallion perhaps no matter what
he did in life but today we're talking
primarily about his work in astrophysics
that garnered him along with andre guess
my colleague up at ucla who i still hope
to get on the into the impossible
podcast please if you are listening out
there andrea i'd love to have you on
uh but we also get into the importance
of mentorship of how he learned from
really two men in his life two father
figures one his actual father ludwig who
is a great physicist himself you'll hear
him touchingly and lovingly talk about
his late father and also his ideological
father charlie towns nobel laureate from
uc berkeley who really inspired this
quest to look in the infrared to peer
through the dust that conceals and
constrains our vision of the inner
workings of the milky way galaxy he's
going to hear about that where do we go
from here what can we do with these uh
with this technology and what he's most
excited about so now sit back come along
on a ride into the impossible with
professor reinhart gensel and yours
truly brian keating any sufficiently
advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
open the pod bay doors now welcome
everybody to another edition of the into
the impossible podcast i am your fearful
host dr brian keating
and we have had a segment on this
podcast for a long time now called nobel
mines where we have featured to date
nine nobel laureates in physics
still trying to get some other
disciplines reinhardt but uh but so far
they've they've all been too busy those
economists they get they get very busy
uh but
but reinhardt is uh is a legendary
experimental uh and uh
and astrophysicist he's the co-director
of the max pike institute for
extraterrestrial physics
uh professor at lmu emeritus professor
at uc berkeley up
eight from here and he was awarded the
2020 nobel prize in physics along with
andrea guezz and sir roger penrose
andrea has yet to answer my emails to
come on the show i'm hoping she will
but roger was on three or four times
just last year and you and i celebrated
along with the world sir roger's 90th
birthday not too long ago and i thought
it'd be a great opportunity to introduce
the world to the astrophysics that you
do with your collaboration
and uh and then we could have a
discussion about black holes and how
mysterious and wonderful they are and
where the future of this field is going
to go so first of all reinhardt thank
you so much for joining us on the
podcast
so i thought maybe you could show your
slides um that you showed at sir rogers
90th birthday party uh just a few weeks
back in august 2021
uh sir roger is now three billion
seconds old
uh but he doesn't look a day over you
know 2 billion 999 million
yeah he's an amazing person he's amazing
he really is and he's been a great
friend and indulged me in some of my
questions about uh singularities um
extremal black holes and other things i
hope to get into with you so ryan you
know you know ryan of course i mean we
might might come to this later but you
know this
you know
the weirdness of black holes of course
often leads to interesting questions
from the audience
and you know one of the more common ones
of course has to do with wormholes yeah
and i never knew what really i could say
about this because i mean
yeah it's a speculation but you know why
would you test it in reality so i asked
i asked roger i said roger you know i'm
being accosted by these questions and
you know you're an authority in this you
know
tell me what do you think about hormones
and he says oh rubbish
i remembered that we met each other in
2005
at the 90th birthday party for charlie
towns who was your advisor and i later
want to talk about recollections of
charlie towns i know he was a titanic
influence in your life and really
the the path to the nobel prize really
goes in in large part you know alongside
him with your work
so um so yeah if you would take us on
your 40-year journey that will uh take
us back uh to where this all began so
yeah please uh yeah well so i mean
basically i mean there's sort of like a
russian doll situation here
uh in the innermost part there is uh the
research which i'm associated with
the institute and of course
in the us
andrei i guess
and
that's the inner part of the russian
dollar the next layer of course is the
more general question of
whether these objects which general
relativity
predicts to exist
black holes whether they really are
there and so then
what we are doing is just one version of
possible approaches which in fact people
have made
and surprisingly so uh
lately with great success actually uh
to test whether this uh black hole
paradigm as we call it whether that's
correct
the next level of the of the
the doll has to do with the universe as
a more global entity and the fact okay
if you if you have such things as black
holes
what is their role you know who ordered
them so to speak and they have to are
they just there and and what's their
role and so that that is extremely
surprising story which also has been you
know we've been making empirical uh
progress in this then comes the next
layer of the daw which
has to do with general relativity
uh i mean here's a theory which is uh
is to start with
associated with you know extremely
famous theoreticians although einstein
to start with but then others of course
as well
uh schwarzschild
kerr
penrose
etc and so the question then is
is this theory you know correct and then
most
most
theorists but maybe also some of the
experimentalists would say likely not
and and that's sort of surprising here's
one of the
theories which just
i mean
at least on
on the largest scales we know namely
that of the universe rules supreme
and it rules also apparently supreme on
the smaller scales inside
the cores of black holes where there's
supposedly is an infinitely dense thing
called the singularity which you know
most
most of us of course feel are okay
something is missing in the theory which
is
the
the expansion the extension to the
smaller scales as a quantum theory and
that is obviously
obviously missing so this is really
amazing that you know on the one hand
that theory is now 105 years
older blindsided
in berlin
uh
under five years ago and you're still
working on it speaking in fact
uh the experimental studies are just
getting going i mean
you know if we look into the future it's
very clear
where i would put my eggs okay
gravitational waves
that's that's clearly the uh you know
the ultimate way probably
of approaching these things so close as
to then perhaps see some deviations of
general relativity
so i think the uh interesting aspect of
the black holes is how much they
captivate the the mind and the the
intellect of not only you know
professional scientists like us but uh
but the mysteries that they reveal and
provoke in the general public and we've
had on many uh many guests from lenny
suskind obviously sir roger delilah
gates um
and the one thing that keeps coming back
is that these objects are laboratories
and in some sense i was a little bit
surprised when the committee awarded you
and andrea
um you know the prize not they didn't
say black hole right they did
yeah so what is that what was the reason
for that choice of words i mean that's
that's i would say i fully agree with
that
you have to have to
uh you know because and i think that the
nobel committee it's i would say
generally very good about this i mean
remember
the the prize for
um
ricardo jacoby was 2002
and the reason is
is that of course um
what we have not yet shown really
none of the observations have shown is
that the so-called corometric which is
describing the
um in
in theory which is describing what we
would call these objects
without charge
and which have a
two numbers associated with them
according to the theory a mass
and a spin and that is it yeah okay so
that's the remarkable thing that these
objects are
you know extremely simple theoretically
there's only two numbers so that means
the theory says there are no hills there
are no valleys oh you know there's no
hair
and therefore is no hair that's right
and so this this
this test of no hair namely in
mathematical terms that all other
properties of the object in terms of
higher moments mass distribution
can be predicted by these two numbers
that is missing okay that is missing
both from the existing work uh on the
supermass black hole in the galactic
center and it is missing
in fact also for the
uh in spiral of stellar black holes with
ligo and and so that's why you know one
has to be really careful and say well we
have everything we've shown and
everything like or has shown
there are objects which you know look
like black holes and probably are black
holes but
we are still not there
it seems unprovable to say you know
because how else what other evidence
could one gather not not for the
singularity we'll get to that later but
uh for the properties that you know the
event horizon telescope has shown that
ligo has shown that you andrea and your
group has shown uh what else do we need
before well okay
that's a very good question right i
think the answer most people would say
is
no hair theory indeed and
and and so
for the gravitational waves what would
have to be done is
um
is the following if you think of a black
hole as really sort of an entity
and you bang at it
it starts to oscillate okay and so there
is a characteristic
uh what one calls a quasi-quasi-normal
frequency about it which is essentially
the time light takes
to move around the black hole on the
innermost
stable orbit for the light that's called
a photon orbit
and so if you if you suppose you know
the mass of the black hole exceedingly
well
and then you had a you know a piece of
light going around this this innermost
stable orbit and it would exactly follow
that over the time scale
then you have proven and you knew of
course the spin i should say
you know the mass and the spin and now
you make that measurement of this
orbital time scale of the photons then
then you really have group minority one
version of it and indeed that's exactly
what in principle the gravitational wave
community would like to do why haven't
they done it
well because the objects which they have
looked at so far namely stellar black
holes
have a very short time scale
of 100 milliseconds less for this time
and there is not much time to build up
signal noise ratios
so it's just a practical thing the
objects are small
shut the time scales are short and in
fact because they are small the signals
are really weak although they are
actually
and the the objects are not that far
away so the ultimate object everyone
knows is a massive black hole
and it's still a black hole which
inspires into it
for that you cannot do that on the
ground because of the frequencies of the
orbital
spiral is much too long
initially at least
but because it's long you can make very
exceedingly precise measurements so the
space mission we all hope to have in
space about 50-20 years
might do that okay so then
another way of doing it is uh
in the galactic center is to uh
you know measure the measure to spin
we're trying to do this with stars which
is still further in than the ones which
we had seen previously
um if you're lucky we will see such a
star and then
if the
radio astronomers could measure the size
of the photon orbit so to speak
it's called the shadow of the black hole
we know the mass exceedingly well then
we have a test of the
of the
ethereum as well so i think there's
there's good hope that this this will
actually come about but then as you say
this does not solve the quantum problem
of the of the whole thing quantum
problem number one is we will not be
able to
send
one of us into a with a rocket into the
center of the black hole and and check
out the singularity and then say hey uh
it's it's actually not the
plunk things it's two times the point
link or something like this because we
cannot send out any information right i
mean so that's that's the real problem
the other problem is
the so-called information paradox which
is basically
as far as the
classical theory is
if you if you throw in rocks
or
refrigerators and a few cars and
everything else into the black hole
black hole will all forget that
and so if you come back later and check
it out so to speak you wouldn't know any
evidence but the quantum theory would
tell you no absolutely not the quantum
numbers are stored somewhere
and there's even some proposals where
they might be stored namely exactly on
the inventorized surface
and so then it might drift out like
fumes
like quantum fumes
and so if you want to speculate that
that may be maybe sort of a
thing of the future and of course
it could be that you know this this this
will change the
the properties near the event horizon
enough that it's measurable
it's extremely fascinating that you know
it takes 100 years and you're still not
there's
yeah and the more that we learn the more
mysterious these objects become uh i
talk with lenny suskin who does have
this proposal of the stretched horizon
as you just said the kind of one you
know planck length above the what we
would consider to be the event horizon
i actually don't think it's a important
distinction that you know we say oh we
can't observe these things in in theory
even because the event horizon shields
it uh what i have an issue with is that
people will talk about
the need for quantum gravity based on
the existence of an unobservable
singularity uh either in a black hole or
at the origin of the universe which i
study so these are two as roger and
stephen hawking showed uh unobservable
even in in principle uh regimes and uh
no that's not to say that they're right
uh it could be that the uh that there
was a collapsing
epoch before the universe originated as
you as you probably know your advisor
charlie towns when he won his nobel
prize his students arno penzias and and
robert wilson were busy measuring the
cmb and when they measured the cmb in
1964 and then released in 1965 uh their
interpretation well i should say the
interpretation of jim peebles and robert
dickey and others was that it was the
after effect of uh pre-collapsing phase
to the universe that we had witnessed
the cycle they never mentioned the big
bang once
in that paper and i think a lot of
people had trouble with that the notion
of fred hoyle and others um and i wonder
what do you make of these controversies
in physics the late great stephen
weinberg he just passed away uh he used
to say that physics thrives on crises
but luckily there aren't so many crises
well
i mean i think first of all of course
this is the scientific principle and
that's what's
what makes us indeed
capable of telling truth
from fake news okay
the famous fake news
and that is that we have a say a theory
in this case which is
already pretty well tested in some
regimes
and we keep getting going at it okay
i mean i but you know
people are different i think i've um
you know
even very good astrophysical theorists
would tell me say a few years ago
before our latest breakthrough in a way
uh reinhardt why why are you doing this
i mean everyone knows that general
relativity is correct
uh
okay much much more important is to
speak the cosmological evolution of the
blackboard that that is important
because that affects
galaxies and how they grow or not grow
but but why do why do you try to test
general relativity well because my my
physics side tells me
you
if
know
can't verify
all the predictions of the theory then
the theory is
is in danger so to speak no it could be
wrong
and we better we better check it out and
in this particular case of course
by testing generativity in the galactic
center we are also testing
this this this paradigm that galactic
nuclei in fact almost all galaxies you
know i think
have such a such a beast in their midst
and
and and in fact it's a symbiotic
relationship right so that people grew
up together and grown again and after a
while
the black hole became active typically
and started actually uh you know
damaging some of the galaxy
embedded in
when i um when i think about the future
of your field i do i definitely want you
to show these wonderful images that you
showed at roger's birthday
fest shrift as you might say but uh
before you do
um you know the thought occurred to me
that a lot of what we've learned in
recent years thanks to ligo and other
projects was also what falls under
what's known as multi-messenger
astronomy where you observe something in
light
in electromagnetic waves and in
gravitational waves is there hope with
the tools that you and your colleagues
are developing that there could be a
multi-messenger signal say if if one of
these gas clouds s2 or whatever you guys
called if one of those were to be
gobbled up and you were to witness it
with your ao technology etc on a massive
telescope
and is there any hope that ligo or some
perturbation to the milky way's black
hole that that could be a
multi-messenger signal that would tell
us something it's a very very
interesting question i mean
the answer
at first would have to be yes but highly
unlikely okay um
why unlikely well the the situation is
for moderately
small black holes
the stars which they come too close
do get disrupted
so to speak and then
outside of the event horizon and then
they fall
into
partly at least into the black hole part
of it gets ejected
and actually
it in the galactic center there is some
evidence
we have
that there is gas on
an orbit which is almost straight in if
you like
um
which which
which went into the central region and
then came back out again
uh on on this orbit but it's gas not not
a not another star
or at least not only a star and this gas
cloud was extended and so it's very very
much possible
that that is one of a case of one one of
a you know a class of stars which from
time to time you know do in fact come so
close to the center of a galaxy that
they would get disrupted and at that
time of course
you would see
gravitational waves the problem is
that this statistically speaking happens
once every uh 30 000 years or so so the
chances of catching one of them and that
all in the galactic center is really
very low in the more general sense
absolutely not i think in the general
sense
we are now in a in
a time as you well know where people are
looking for these transients
and they're fighting and so
if you then have a sensitive enough
gravitational wave detector you could
look uh
at these regions and perhaps detect them
so chances are that this will will be
possible whether it's happening in the
galactic center there we really have to
appeal to
a lot of luck
this is sort of a very nice movie which
in fact andrea made
about 10 years ago um
to just show the inner works here if you
like so these are our test particles or
stars which we've been looking at and
it's remarkable
any theories
20 years ago when we discovered these
would have
sworn
that these stars cannot exist why
well you know
we have a very good theory of course
in principle
how these clusters around a black hole
or stars should look like
and that is because the dominant thing
is gravity right and so
stars if they're heavy
will over time move toward the center
that's correct and get close to the
black hole but the time it takes are
billions of years
these objects which we're seeing here in
this movie
all are less than say 50 million years
old
so they couldn't have possibly
over time by equilibrium processes as we
say
um
you know moved into the center so the
question is therefore
how did they
and so they are in a tremendous gift to
us because some of these stars
in fact not few this year we had
another three stars coming in
uh just like this famous star s2 who did
in 2002 and then again in 2018 and came
as close as about 15 light hours
so that's sort of that you know
on the order of 100 times the distance
between
the sun and the earth so that's solar
system scales yeah tremendous okay
tremendous that gives us the
this ultimate way of testing it because
it does go so deep into the into the
central region but how you know who did
that
who who made these stars go in there and
so that's
one of these things in in in science and
say in astronomy is certainly that the
universe has all these surprises for us
and sometimes the surprises are
wonderful right
they really
they really helped the field to go
forward enormously because
before we had this orbit of this
particular star
we had sort of a statistical
assessment of the situation not that it
would be any different but i mean most
physicists would have said yeah that
sounds plausible that there is a mass in
there
but like oh why
could it not be a cluster of neutron
stars or something else and that's
that's exactly the despite the fact that
we had this breakfast worldwide and the
bell committee
is still
a little cautious on this because
uh we
we could you could you could think
although not really anymore that is not
a single block wall for instance but you
know a double block but you think we
have now actually excluded that also at
least to the extent that the second
object is is more massive than say a
thousand smaller masses or so
but i mean there's all of these things
you have to check in and that's the
check check out and so that's where
uh time is needed and that's where these
journeys become uh pretty long long live
but but you're right
if you then get someone to help you like
gravitational waves or
very very interesting for us would be it
is radio imaging
and then
then you could make progress in much
yeah and when i think about the you know
technology versus the theoretical
technology you know the hardware versus
the
you know software so to speak um i think
about ligo obviously tremendous
technology
and it's a purely relativistic uh in a
sense event horizon you know people
quibble are you really seeing the event
horizon or just the light shadow you
already mentioned that i think they're
both fascinating
but still you need numerical relativity
you need um to treat it purely
relativistically and interferometry has
been around for you know what 80 90
years it wasn't new technology in that
sense but i would say um the technology
that you employ you know adaptive optics
uh laser guiding etc etc um i think that
might be interesting for my audience
because typically they're hearing about
well this is a test of pure general
relativity but if i'm if i'm not
mistaken the fastest velocity of say s2
was about a few percent of the speed of
light
so you wouldn't necessarily i mean you
could do a lot with kepler
just using kepler not einstein and so in
a sense the uh the compact object or or
whatever as a test laboratory for
general relativity it's also a test for
classical relativity which makes it more
interesting to me in a sense uh that the
the adaptive optics and the and the
story of this 40-year journey as you
described it um where that begins and
and how how can we see through this i
mean if you look up at the milky way and
i've been to the southern hemisphere
i've been you know i've seen the
magellanic you can't see
you know sag a star with your naked eye
that's just something
the milky way is this rotten filthy
place with lots of dust just like los
angeles is and
i want to know um how can you see
through the dust i mean how is this even
possible that uh that we could penetrate
through this cloud that veils our vision
and obscures everything
right so so that that brings us back to
the 70s actually and and in fact
charles towns and his his morgan berkley
uh which i whom i then joined as a
postdoc initially and then as a faculty
member
[Music]
in the early 80s so the situation was
uh that the so-called quasars had been
discovered in the 1960s
uh by the radio astronomers looking just
you know what does the radio sky look
like and they found compact radio
sources pretty bright
and then they asked their
optical colleagues why did you take a
picture of those and what do you see and
and then they used polymer and they came
back and said well they look like stars
not very interesting
and but so luminous how would that be
and then
then the trick was that once you look at
their spectra in the optical you can see
that they're actually highly redshifted
in terms of their line image and
therefore if you interpret that that
redshift as an effect of expanding your
universe and
you apply then the sort of the
conversion from from redshift into
distance and all of a sudden these
objects
uh you know are billions of light years
away and and so what looks like a little
star actually says no must be luminous
so that went on in the 1960s and
okay people will start to think you know
what create all of this energy and
turns out if you if you would pack stars
in that region uh even if you if you
work hard on it
it won't it won't give you the the kind
of
phenomenon you would see because right
by that time not only optical light had
been seen in radio light but also x-rays
and gamma rays your multi-messenger uh
as you see and so so so it was clear
these are unusual objects you really
have to and so luminous 1000 to up to
100 000 times more luminous than the
entire milky way how can you can have
that
and that's where the this crazy idea of
black holes came in now they weren't
called call black holes back then they
were called schwarzschild's
throats
the strange word for nowadays okay
should watch your throats
and so that that is within it within a
decade people basically
convince themselves that the most
efficient way to generate energy is to
let material fall onto a big black hole
and before the material disappears
behind the event horizon that energy
which is released can be leading to this
enormous amount of radiation
so next question how do you test that
well to test gravity we know what we
have to do we think of the solar system
right i mean the solar system has our
sun dominating the entire mass and you
have planets
and so if you go back to trisha brah and
kepler right way
to do this right is you basically
observe the motions of the planets
and
then you use kepler's laws or on newton
and then you find that if there is a
dominant central mass and the
planets are always on that mass well
then the
innermost planets move faster
than the outer ones by an absolutely
predictable amount and if you test that
in the solar system then you you have so
to speak
you know
prove that the sun dominates
the mass by far
well so this same idea you would
want to use
also inquisitors but they're too far
away that was really very clear they
were too far away
and so then it was a
critical paper by
two british very famous theorists
donald lindenbell and martin ruiz
in 71 who basically speculated at the
time well maybe maybe these black holes
which
have been talked about by these quasars
are not only present in these rare
quasars
but maybe they are
they're everywhere
perhaps every galaxy has and it's just
that only a few
are excreting material at such rates
that they
are bright and are called increases and
in fact that's our picture nowadays not
at that time so what's the closest
galaxy therefore well all
by a huge factor
and so in the paper in this 1971 paper
lindenwell reason actually you made a
little recipe of what should be done
it's not exactly how it it didn't
mention stars
and molecules were not alone at the time
so they proposed more h1 observations
etc etc and variability studies and so
forth
but in the end i mean that's that's the
idea so
uh
so let's go ahead and observe the
galactic center and observe all of this
and the answer of course is with the
radio you can but you can't get really
close enough at least not at that time
and what about just looking at the stars
or and so forth and that is impossible
because of the dust
in front of the galactic center which
attenuates optical light by so much even
nowadays we cannot
practically observe the galactic center
in what we would call the optical
band
but if you go to slightly longer
wavelengths by say a factor of a few
the extinction is so strongly dependent
on wavelength
that you can peer through
the dust stream at a few micrometers and
certainly at 10 micrometers
and that's where towns came in because
towns
you see he got his nobel prize for the
invention of the laser and the laser
and it was on the east coast in many
years and all of that then at some point
he decided to
move to move
west to california
and
start a new profession as an astronomer
okay
but he knew of course things which
astronomers didn't know which which was
your laser's mazes and
he knew about the
possibly very exciting
possibilities with infrared light
and infrared is exactly what you need
and so that he
he and his students then build a
spectrometer and
use that spectrometer to look at doppler
shifts of ionized gas in an infrared
line
near the galactic center and sure enough
they saw
that the emotions of those glass clouds
were very large i mean when i then
joined we did ever more of that and so
by the mid 80s we we had a he wrote a
big nature paper
saying the galactic center is infused
a few solar million solar mass
blackboard
so there it is
uh you know
mid 80s so that's uh 40 years or 30 30
plus years ago so it's it's clear that
we thought we had other towns
felt okay more or less we're done
but nobody else believed as you see and
that's it
without adaptive optics i mean i know
the story i've had claire max uh in
conversation before and adaptive optics
i understand was was embargoed it was
the national security and etc and we
were
that's yeah okay so so at this point in
the 80s
70s 80s we we used infrared and long
wavelengths infrared where adaptive
optics actually doesn't really do much
uh 10 microns
with embed plus we didn't have eight me
ten meter class telescopes okay so we
would we would observe on
on four three meter class telescopes and
ten microns and there
you know if you have good seeing on
malachai you're doing okay
and this in the technique at that time
as i said you you measure the spectra by
spectroscopy
the doppler motions and so that that
but the reason
the reason people felt
that they wouldn't believe us was
exactly that maybe they said well
clouds of gas are very tenuous things
plus it's ionized gas ionized gas you
know you can push around
with magnetic fields you can push it
around with stellar winds how do you
know that this is what you're measuring
is gravity how do you know that this is
orbiting gas could it be that it's
actually
ejected gas and so forth and there's
some truth to that
although
what we know now is is does show that we
have the right rotation but the question
is whether it's believable so
the big jump then came into the 90s step
number one
exchange gas by stars
try to move the motions of the stars
and
then
make the make that measurement as
precisely as you can and precise in this
case means you have to measure the the
centroid of
of a stellar
object to more than one over 100 of its
diameter due to the seeing or
the
resolution of your telescope and that's
why indeed it became clear you cannot do
that with normal
techniques
so that's where initially we used
speckle imaging
where you would take short exposures
and
in in any short exposure in any short
time the atmosphere so to speak then
still more or less stationary
but after about
you know thousands of a second then the
you know then the image gets distorted
and then then two things happened at the
end of that phase
which is number one we all went to
bigger telescopes andrea first in the
mid 90s we had the
2001
um and then adaptive optics now you
mentioned that already that the story of
adaptive optics actually like the
detectors we were using i mean the
imaging detectors and the infrared also
had the same if you like heritage
like adaptive optics namely
that for a long time not now anymore but
at that time they were all
products
of military developments in
the united united states because
of course the military people wanted to
look at russian orbits
and satellites
and that was their way of
you know look in the infrared of course
you can look at the
the the hot
exhaust of
of rockets as they get launched
and that's the way to to predict so to
speak okay there is an attack coming
like this and so that's how the imaging
detectors in the infrared came about and
then the adaptive optics came about
because
the military wanted to check out the
details of
of spacecraft up there yeah
and and so
in in the
u.s by
by getting that technology to come out
of the
military sector the classified sector
was wonderful and
who did it towns
because towns actually
was deep
deeply involved in many
of these connections between research
and the government and
not the end of the cold war or the
jason's he was a that's right exactly
yeah yeah he
he was the one to suggest that jason b
found it and
um
no it's clear i mean i should say in
europe um
there was a civilian type development
both with adaptive optics but also infra
detectors and initially that couldn't
couldn't be on par with the us just
because you know the amount of money you
have to have in order to develop a
system like that initially is
so high that
the kind of money astronomers had in
either us or
you know wasn't enough but
nowadays it's different actually so that
you know the
nowadays astronomers develop the
top technologies to take this as a force
themselves i'm mentioning this because
um martin howard
once wrote a very
influential book
um
where he basically his thesis is that
without the
access to
military technology
astronomy never would have gotten word
where it is now any others it's true to
them actually trusted that certainly in
space yeah there's always been a
partnership from galileo the first
telescopes that he invented or he used
he tried to sell to the venetian senate
to use for military spying on ships in
the lagoons of
venice and that was one of the first
things he realized he could make money
off of astronomy
and so yeah there's always been some
connection between the military and
and um and now we see you know basically
the hubble uh space telescope uh is is
kind of on a par with some of the best
military spy satellites except it looks
in the opposite direction and speaking
of space what would your project your
you know the gravity group what would
what would be the evolution and what
could a space borne you know where you
don't even need adaptive optics um or
you know are we going to be there with
things like jwst or are we going to be
able to observe
future follow-ups to not only the
massive black hole in our galaxy but
maybe in others as well in the infrared
that's a very good question and
i would say
at first
most of us thought
uh that the sky was the limit and indeed
you would go ahead and build ever bigger
telescopes in space
and
you see i i've had the the privilege to
be associated with two major space
projects as a pi institute
as well as being chair of those
committees on the european side isa the
european space agency and so initially
for very long wavelengths
infrared astronomy and far infrared
astronomy
we all were thinking about an object in
a telescope
of substantial size in fact the u.s
thought they could launch a 30 meter
telescope 30 meters now you have no
rocket where this would fit in
therefore the idea was
you may
you know may recall these pictures of
you know
uh astronauts uh you know assembling
such structures uh in in near-earth
and
building this as it was called the large
deployable reflector now that fell apart
for the following reasons
reason number one
we astronomers learned that near earth
orbits is no good absolutely no good
and even if she had a telescope there it
would still be disturbed by the earth
and because of its thermal influence all
the space chunk up there etc etc so we
want certainly in the infrared but also
now because we migrated background
studies and so forth you want to get
away from earth as much as possible
and
okay so no astronauts you know with a
screwdriver
so you would then think about like in
case of james webb telescope
uh structures which you can fold
and then when the launch is
taking place you basically unfold and so
forth well that's very risky very risky
and we'll see i really really hope when
james webb will be launched and it will
actually unfold as
as prescribed and so in europe
we felt that this was just not not
possible unfortunately because
he had a similar mission which the end
got
launched as a three and a half meter
telescope but it started as a deployable
eight meter telescope and we had hoped
it would be that size and and in the end
the engineers in these are said no it's
too risky
whether that's the right decision or not
i don't know certainly
you know historically i would say
the more cautious europeans
and
as a result of their being more cautious
they've went faster actually i mean the
james webb
has been on the books
since the 90s okay they still don't have
it out there
and
now let's go to interferometry and here
this story is quite similar
in principle you know it's obvious what
you have to do right i mean you have to
take
the launch
you know
four
say
two
and a half week class telescope or
something like this
into space and then you know we do you
know magic to
align them that should be possible i
mean that's how aliza
also will want to
operate the problem again is station
keeping
technology
and then the cost certainly in europe
um
we just had a review again of the of the
ether space station that brought in dr
kony and and they looked at a
space interferometer again
and in the end
threw it out
and
even in the u.s i mean the
idea of a space interferometer was
around
two two
one or two decay that the cable reviews
ago right the tpf the terrestrial planet
finder my god i mean that's what
everyone would like to do
but it wasn't realized too costly and so
there is i'm afraid there is a
sort of a truth in martin howard is
statement
that there is sort of a limit
i call that the region of death
it's like in the supercollider yeah if a
project
becomes larger than something and the
james webb is is awfully close to that
yeah then
at least you have to
be fearful of that your project gets
dragged out for
uh you know sheer incredible amounts of
time
more than perhaps the
you know the lifetime of a single
scientist
but by the care if you if you go too far
into this territory of death
it's just
societies will not or at least
understandably will hesitate that's
right to spend that much money so that's
why i would say i'm afraid uh
for now it's
it's gravity and here i want to come
back to charlie towns and towns
wrote once a very nice
piece for any reviews of astronomy
that's one of these chapters on you know
himself
and he described what he had done in
astronomy and
amongst
you will find deformatory yeah okay now
you said interferometry is 90 years old
that's absolutely correct for the radio
astronomy side but you go to the
infrared
where you are much shorter wavelength
the atmosphere is
is
a shorter coherence time
and on top of it typically you have
larger bandwidth all of this conspires
to make the problem
more difficult however by the fact over
100 000 or so
and so what is a pretty obvious thing to
do in the
radio
and still pretty obvious in the
millimeter becomes absolutely you know
extremely difficult in in the article
and now thomas did it
and
he used the trick at the time he used 10
microns again so a little longer
and he transformed the
the the long wavelength 10 micron
radiation into the radio
through mixing
okay so mixing with lasers and and so
that made it possible for him to do
information in his take in this in this
wonderful little paper of this he
actually says what i really want to do
in the end is to look at the black hole
with interferometry wow so that's what
we have now done in fact unfortunately
uh we succeeded only after it's passed
away but i i knew what yeah we were
doing but
now
just to tell you i mean the
effort or the the complexity in the end
the sensitivity all of this what we in
the end had to realize was about i would
say a hundred thousand times better with
it watch how he
had done there so that's about a plan to
use the
two telescopes of keck to do
interferometry either in the optical or
in the
uh you know some micron and
i to my knowledge didn't it didn't
produce anything it was a
vast technical challenge and maybe it
will maybe it won't someday but yeah
it's it's exponentially harder to do it
for the reasons that you mentioned
and i want to take uh one other step
maybe laterally
and you know and focus on these these
questions that you kind of are a rare
reinhardt because you have a commanding
knowledge of the experimental side of
the practical side but you also
obviously understand the theoretical
implications a lot of my uh work in
you know as a teacher as an experimental
astrophysicist and communicator is to
tell people that there are other people
you know sir roger is wonderful you know
stephen hawking is wonderful but these
are theoreticians and i almost feel like
a good experimentalist should should
know the theory as well as a theorist
but maybe not create new theories i mean
i think that's too much but if you're
just you know just applying you know the
technology without understanding the
theory i don't think that's a
fulfillment of what an experimentalist
should do and so i guess what i'm asking
you is what is your philosophy of a
well-rounded scientist charlie was a
paramount person like that in the
tradition of enrico fermi you know one
of the last people that could do theory
that could do experiment um that
understood the fundamental question what
is your philosophy the students that you
mentor the postdocs etc what do you try
to implicate in them to have them
fulfill their potential as a complete
scientist
right i mean
i would not
uh
have
the audacity to say that i understand
the theoretical
work at the depths which is needed in
the end to make reliable um statements
okay so for instance you know if you
want to
um
investigate you know
this style the star cluster in the
center and make a proposal how these
stars would come about that's
sufficiently complicated i would say
that you know i certainly wouldn't be
able to
uh to do that and so here's rule number
one
is you have to have a
team and after all that is what happens
it's not a single individual here it's a
substantial team which in our case of
course grew over time
was initially largely based at mpe but
is now european okay i mean the
interferometry is is uh
really involves
at this point about a hundred people
so
that's that's clearly not done anymore
even at a
pretty well-endowed max funk institute
but it's it's a range of people in a
team so that you know you can you can
talk to people about the various things
and thomas knew that as well now of
course his
mantra i sort of know
people at nasa are doing this stuff and
the other thing no i don't want to do
that i i think the best science is done
only with a student yeah
hans would insist on that on that
philosophy
that's why i would not agree with him i
mean the the fact you know we talked
about in the pharmacy you can invent in
in hindsight you can you know talk sees
the voluntary as a as an incredible
amount of pioneering
of of a field but you could also call it
a failure
because you know that he wouldn't get to
the galactic center type
sensitivities was clear after a
really short period of time
and so this
you have to you have to bite the bullet
sometimes you have to realize okay if
you want to get there with this type of
technique
to get that kind of resolution
you will have to go into a different
domain of work
and that then includes larger teams and
that
includes collaborations towns would like
to
collaborate with other teams it was
always you know the fifth floor and
verge i mean that's that's how how we
lived up there everyone you know up
there was part of the gang but
but i mean i i think i think i am very
proud
that over time i managed
to
bring to fruition and create what i call
my champions league team
so we
we have people in munich
who are you know top people world-class
people by themselves could be could be
you know top people anywhere and
the fact that they
in the end chose to stay rather than
become professor elsewhere may not
happen too but
uh
is
i'm extremely glad for that because
that's the kind of thing
now of course another thing which i
would say is important in addition to
this
range of things you have to write you
have to write you have to write kind of
hunting
skill or smell
okay you have to know
what is and what isn't possible and
where
you know the time is right to get in
i mean again i could go with the
informatory and say of course i mean i
grew up as a radio struggler in my
thesis as a student i used via bldi to
to look at water vapor measures in the
emotions so i i'm you know i'm an
interferometrist at heart still it was
clear
until you know about 15 years ago that
information in the infrared
forget it yeah not at the kind of
sensitive but now that's very different
what we are what we are looking at here
is sort of the central few arc seconds
in the upper left of the galactic center
the the upper left is the the best you
can do with a
a 10 meter class telescope in seeing
limited conditions so what do you see
you see some very bright
here dark
stars okay these these objects are
really very massive actually yeah some
of them are 100 solar mass uh
world freight stars and their most stars
very near the center now the center is
right in the middle
okay
and so if you had radio eyes
then you would see in this very center
this compact radio source edges which
consider the first
x marks the spot kind of uh
their situation so the the adaptive
optics then
improves this image from the top left to
the top right by about a factor of 20
in resolution so with a 10 meter
telescope now an adaptive optics on
under very good conditions yeah wow now
you can see individual stars very
clearly some of the brighter ones of
course you can see the artifacts of the
adaptive optics not being perfect you
see this ringing there
and then now in the center all of a
sudden yeah there it is
that's a j star that's the black hole
which also there also radiates
okay
and it's just on the top part of it
there's a little spot the the upper part
of the small square that's that star s2
so this image actually is from this here
so this star s2 which has been our
key
object to look at for these orbits
is already now it was gone
outside of the center
this year okay
it was very near in fact more or less on
top of on these scales of the of the
central object
but now the interferometry so
go here now from this upper right image
to the lower right image
okay and again that's the little this
little square which you see
is now what you see as a big square on
the bottom yeah okay
and whoops
what do you see
not only one object but heck
uh one two three four five six or
whatever yeah and that in fact is is
what
um
what the breakthrough is the
breakthrough is the resolution and
therefore the precision
of
measuring things very accurately but the
other thing is also also of course
we can actually now with this kind of in
the problem finally go deep
and so
these these fainter stars which you see
there are fainter than what you can see
in adaptive optics
on the upper
image mainly because of confusion
it's not that you know a single single
adaptive optics is just a telescope can
go very very deep
but in a crowded field like this that's
not the limit the limit is really how
you can distinguish
and then you take
several of these images over three
months and then you get the
left
the bottom left okay
so red was in in
march
green is is may and blue is
is july
and wow i mean you look at that i mean
there's
very obviously one star which came
extremely close even closer than s2
another one instead of moving the other
way and there are a few more yeah so
it's
that's really the the key thing and i i
would say
the informatory
is a
very serious contender now in my view
for certain types of measurements one
would like to do
one other application where it's been a
breakthrough without our actually
expecting it
was a
exoplanet
spectrum
so
you wouldn't think that i mean
if you think about these exoplanets
the problem is you have a planet and
then you have a much much much much
brighter central star
and the way usually this is dealt with
is um
you you basically
mask
you mastered the bright star and then
you look only at the planet well with
adaptive optics that's fine
because then the star becomes radically
compact you can actually see the planet
but
the adaptive optics is not perfect
and the and the star is say a billion
times
or certainly a million times brighter
than the
planet and a little bit of this
uncorrected light is then
you know floating around
near the planet and generates noise
so the noise is now not any more
instrumental so to speak but it's due to
uncompensated uh
light from the scattering from the star
right right yeah and so
the interferometry on the other hand
uh doesn't do that because
the same effect in the adaptive optic
systems on the on the individual
telescopes which we're using also make
uh
not not perfect correctors but they're
not correlated and so the the formula
blends that out completely so that's why
all of a sudden the
currently the spectra which you're
producing with gravity of exoplanets
uh are the best in the world by a fact
of 10
are there any applications of
polarimetry i know that in reflectometry
et cetera how do you how how can that be
used to enhance the scientific data
well i mean the galactic center
what happens is you see let's again look
at the bottom left there so this is what
looks like a you know a
light blue object in the center that's
rg star
so if you take a time trace of that then
you would see varying
on typically time scales of 30 minutes
or so
which by the way is this
orbital time scale of gas
on the innermost stable orbit okay so
that's our interpretation that's what
you're seeing here is very very hot
about 10 10 billion 100 billion degrees
or 100 billion degrees
uh gas which is doing uh
superior radiation so it's polarized
typically 10 to 30 percent
so in fact by
you know
using wave plates
we can analyze the polarization of the
emission and what we find is that
the polarization is is highly aligned
and so with that technology we can
actually study magnetic fields yes in
the vicinity of the black world
extremely exciting yes
extremely exciting because
uh one of the tenets in this field is
that what you're seeing here
most people would say is gas which has
been decreated although not like a
quasar but at very low levels so there's
a small amount of
stuff falling into the galactic center
people would say
say an asteroid every two days or
something like this yeah on this order
and
and that would explain the amount of
radiation which we see
and then the magnetic field would be
not in a disc but in a sort of a
donut
of this hot gas
and if if if the gas is dense well then
as you know the magnetic field is tied
to the gas and then it will be dragged
along in this this like configuration
and would have sort of a toroidal
uh
shape
when you look at what we're seeing
from the variability that's not the case
it's not terrible it's it's polaroid so
you know probably determined by the
black hole
a similar thing is that's been found by
the eht
measurements um in m87 so
that that that really is a sort of a bit
of a shock that
the the
magnetic field structure is is tied to
the black hole itself rather than
to the equation zone so that's the kind
of stuff which you you know
detect on on the side you know when you
were used right yeah yeah it was an
unintentional serendipitous discovery i
think about you know all the things that
uh
when i you know the founder of this
field obviously einstein in some sense
i had a conversation with barry barish
last year and actually inspired me to
write a second book about the uh called
think like a nobel prize winner
hopefully you'll be in volume two but
barry was the inspiration for volume one
and the reason was when he uh told me
that he suffers from the imposter
syndrome and i said oh yeah i'm sure you
did when you were at berkeley as a kid
and you know and you were you know
around people like lawrence and whatever
now he's like no no i feel the imposter
syndrome now uh even after winning the
nobel prize because when i got my nobel
prize i don't know if this happened to
you reinhardt you're a very curious
person just like barry is but he looked
through the logbook
um i actually don't know if you've
gotten the metal whatever you've gotten
you've gotten but he said when he
accepted it in in sweden he looked
through the log book to see who won it
in the past and he saw fineman and
charlie and and he saw fermi and he saw
einstein he's like oh my god i'm not
worthy i'm not worthy he's he's too good
and i'm not good enough and i said come
on you're you know einstein was um he
felt like he was an impostor compared to
uh to isaac newton he actually wrote
about isaac newton as being you know the
creator of all of western civilization
and then i i pointed out that isaac
newton felt uh inadequate compared to
jesus christ
i mean look
ryan it's very clear that amongst every
group of people
and nobel laureates are just another
group of people
there's a range of
excellence if you like and and
but then you know i i think i'm a little
more cautious with the how shall we say
the ultimate
einsteinian
adoration because i mean
if you look
you know
einstein did all of this yeah but
it's not that he found the first
solution right i mean that's when i was
structured and and
other things like the expanding universe
you wouldn't believe that he wasn't the
wrong train there
and you know and and certainly the whole
issue of philosophical discussion uh of
of the quantum theory and so forth he
was not always on the right side so he
had his failures too yeah i know
i always joke that it's too bad that he
had that blunder because he could have
had a good career but actually what
you're saying is exactly aligned with
what i was going to ask you which is
that you know given that einstein didn't
really believe in black holes he he
called lemaitre's idea atrocious
he uh thought that gravitational waves
would never be detected he thought that
uh you know the quantum theory was uh
was unrealistic and
and and should be based on reality and
measurable principles um what aspect of
your career might you say might people
look back on you know 100 years from now
and say oh well reinhardt was he was too
timid he he wasn't he really didn't
realize how powerful things could get is
there anything like that or do you feel
like you're very optimistic about the
future of your subfield and physics in
general that we are going to break to
some ultimate law understanding of
quantum gravity or of the true nature of
the information loss or the nature of
entropy and black holes you know as a
whole what do you make of this
well okay i mean certainly i would say
i'm i'm a very much a pessimist most
people feel that i was liver
now there is pessimism and pessimism
my father would always characterize this
my father was a physicist
by the way
so he said okay well there's
um
two extreme types of people
there's pessimism there's optimism and
there is happy in there
the worst people
are sad pessimists
yeah but
actually happy optimists are not much
better
yeah and so um i
always hope that
yeah i'm
a
positive pessimist but i mean i think
it's clear that we discussed this
already that
we are we
happen to be in astronomy right now in a
absolutely incredible phase yeah and
this will not go on
at this speed
forever okay that's one thing the second
thing is depends on your taste
i'm i use computers uh of course i do
like we all do but i'm not a hacker
and for my taste if i were a new student
now
i don't think i would go into a strong
because i mean i think it's just not my
thing to to
you know
to only sit there and do mcmc and the
rest of it no
[Music]
different people are differently i mean
i mean
i i use i mean if i want to test
something i would test things by
basically looking at the project every
problem from different sites and and
check out plausibility and and so forth
and not only relying on you know
a hundred thousand uh mcmc
if the noise is not gaussian which it
never is that's right
what do you do right
so so i i think i think that's clearly
what in astronomy it's what's
coming next
say on the one hand
huge huge surveys where
you can't really think about anything
anymore but you have to dump it into
some you know artificial intelligence
thing and then then with artificial
intelligence i'm you know i would say
okay
if you if you program the thing to
recognize uh rats and dogs then all of a
sudden there's an elephant in the image
here
what does that what does the artificial
intelligence do okay so sorry for
just
inappropriate comment here but
so that's one side the other side is
that as
absolutely fascinating the exoplanet
story is and will be in terms of
uh you know getting at the chemical
composition
of exoplanets and seeing all these
different types
i think that
wouldn't excite me personally because
this is a personal preference
so i would i would go do something else
instead so
it just
at least for me i was lucky to be in the
right place
at the right time and i think had the
right
mentors
that's
i think i find that extremely important
and i find a little sad that mentors
have gotten lately as a sort of a
concept into a bit of a
bad dis
reputation because people feel okay well
maybe people are abusing
the mentorship in in some some fashion
um
and certainly in a team
if you have only people who say i want
to be i i and i
then as you well know i mean that's
that's not possible you have to give and
take a little bit and it's all
different different types of people
there
when you mentioned you know in in a past
interview you kind of are you consider
yourself the son of two fathers
obviously charlie towns we talked about
talk about your father ludwig what would
you like to tell him you know about
about what what you've discovered and
what you're excited about even
pessimistic as you are
yeah i know my father was uh
you know a super experiment
i mean i'm honor
uh i'm a dwarf compared to my father he
would really do things everything by
himself even even when he was
already pretty bad shape and health-wise
he couldn't really move around anymore
he would go ahead and build little
apparatus of all kinds mostly electronic
type apparatus
and then have young people come and he
would explain it to them
so he loved that enormously and so this
this my father was a
as a physicist was
successful
as a teacher like like like hell he is a
solid state physicist
and i would say
you know
his students and
postdocs and so forth he educated there
must have been
probably 50 professors
yeah no i think it's
very very successful like that and
everyone who heard his lectures uh was
absolutely
excited about them including me
i of course inherited is
superbly written handwritten
notes for lectures and i use them here
in berkeley for you know
for quantum lecture for quantum physics
lectures and so forth really wonderfully
done i mean in in
in a you know very clear
very well spelled out uh but
understandable
yeah not hidden behind you know too much
uh you know complexity and mathematics
but as as
as
obvious as you can make it so that one
was very good now i initially when i was
a
boy i had two things i was like i want
to become an archaeologist um
and then i did a lot of sports
my father didn't like that that was not
good okay clearly now the archaeology
they sort of
evaporated after a little while because
i
realized that
i would have to go to
i thought greece and
egypt was all done
and so where would i go well you know
somewhere in the jungle and jungle had
snakes
etc logo logo or pessimist yeah
vacation in the in coastal and yeah but
in the sports i i really seriously i i
try to
uh you know
go to the olympics i you know almost
made it into the a team but then my
elbow i
did javelin so
yeah i didn't know that what what sport
was that right
track and field so i was yeah yeah no i
was when i was 16 years old i was
germany's best uh germans
wow
but as i said a javelin is a very tricky
discipline because
the
centrical centrifugal force if you throw
the thing more than say 70 meters
at the tendons here okay stress
is so high
that if you're not perfect in technique
uh you basically rip out little bits and
pieces of your tenons which happen to me
it happens to almost every javelin
thrower and then if you don't
immediately get that fixed uh or not
properly fixed and then you're out of
out of business
and i i did also the decades long
pentathlon with these kind of things but
of course once i started physics that i
knew i had to
i had to make the choice
you did win a gold medal
yeah okay
yes
yeah
[Music]
one one question i had for you uh was
your decision to you know to move more
permanently to back to germany was that
more personal or i've heard actually had
lord martin reece on my podcast earlier
this year
and he he was saying you know one of the
models that that's appealing uh is the
max planck
you know institute model where where you
have
more decoupled from from teaching and
the responsibilities that you know say i
have or you had when you were in
berkeley um you know and and yes you
don't get to do the one-on-one with a
student you know or you know my friend
and our friend paul richards you know
with his students and and he's been a
great mentor to me uh but um but you
lose that but on the other hand you have
more kind of
um
i don't know maybe more there's more uh
efficiency because you can only have
post-docs and and there and and
professor level people so was that part
of the reason you moved back to germany
or or well okay i mean i think the
situation
in that sense was complicated i i i love
berkeley i really do
i still do that's why i'm here
[Music]
and
and
world was wonderful family like
california in fact my older daughter
is here permanent thing in in
california so all of this was
wonderful this weather was you know
double a plus
what else would you
better it was clear
that
i mean see the galactic center is not
the only thing i'm doing i mean i'm
doing extra galactic
cosmology
of galaxies and so forth and star
formation and all of that and molecular
spectroscopy and
it was
clear then
that
the kind of resources you would need for
the for both building instruments
but also for doing things
would be definitely above the scale of
a single
nsf grant
and
you see towns it wasn't a totally
different regime if you go back to his
great times when he did the
uh the mazer at columbia
um
the the funding was very much like mark
splunk
there was a colonel from the air force
coming every
every year he said
and
there were
at that time two would nobel laureates
izurabi
and kush
he was the assistant professor okay
in fact cush and robbie tried to get
towns off the of the laser and mesa
right
charlie you know you're a very good
physicist but you know this what you're
doing is not gonna lead anywhere uh you
know we recommend you do some molecular
beams okay don't don't don't do this
this is gonna you know you won't get
tenure
i mean anyhow so
the colonel came
every year and visited the labs that's
what towns told you and basically
walked around and they told them you
know show them equipment they had and so
forth at the end of the day he then then
said well that looks wonderful what you
guys are doing well
i'll make sure the check check is
arriving next week
okay
yes that that was that was how how
things went at that time and in fact
towns for quite a quite a while got this
kind of a deal from the navy
they gave him money directly without
yeah
but of course i when i was trying to do
my thing here like you and everyone else
you know how many proposals are you
writing korea and and for ridiculous
sounds of money yeah okay
you use two weeks to be excellent
for five thousand dollars come on
and
now here in berkeley there was a thing
called radio love radio astronomy love
so they in fact had state funding not
anymore by the way
which means that which is the reason why
the radio lab has ceased to exist
but all the the wonderful discoveries
the millimeter interferometry
the jack welch and in fact countless
discoveries with jack welsh on
on detection of molecules
all were part of the sort of state
funding thing where they had enough
money to have a few senior people poll
stocks etc
and it was clear to me that it's that
kind of
funding was needed
and but ever more impossible and then
came you know clearly the reagan years
were you know there was not all that
much interesting
interest in this kind of okay if you had
connection to nasa different story
uh
but we didn't at the time okay
so that and then on the other hand i
knew mark spark because i had done my my
thesis and the max institute my father
was a much fun director then
so i knew everything about this society
and i
i knew well okay whilst
berkeley is great uh
you know probably max plunk is a little
better absolutely it was i mean that was
that
i mean blue skies or not that was the
right scene and basically you know
this
what they call the long trust
so they basically you know you're being
the process is pretty difficult and
takes a long time but then once you're
hired
you know okay there are visiting
communities coming and checking on you
but
really evidence it's a
wonderful system you don't have to write
proposals unless you want to do
more
than than sort of the standard funding
of the max product group well yeah if
you want to do that then it's very
difficult but
it's it's wonderful i'm not sure here
comes the pessimist
that this system will
you know really
be able to sustain the times
because it's too much in a way
centered on the directors
so we are the senior staff um
we have as i said the champions league
team
is not recognized by the mpg and that's
i don't understand it and and okay now
of course mpg and mpg is not the same
thing i mean
our institute if you like is an extreme
institute in terms of cost experiments
space work and all of that
the typical institute a typical mcspunk
director has a group of maybe 10 15
people you know at the heyday of
herschel we built almost 60
so i mean
there are differences between institutes
but clearly
we are
we are not very well tuned to the
situation that you have very senior
highly
qualified
senior scientists who have essentially
no
official
recognition in society oh okay who's
this
well reinhardt i want to finish up if
you have a couple more minutes left with
some questions that i ask all my guests
that are so gracious with me as you have
been today and uh throughout the time
that i've observed your career and uh
really been fascinated by the by the
breadth and the depth that you engage in
from radio astronomy and work with alma
and apex et cetera and the arakama to to
obviously the work that garnered you
this nobel prize so i want to first ask
you
um a question that i asked kind of in
the spirit of richard feynman who said
that the shortest sentence that
summarizes the most information about
the physical universe
is what he called the atomic hypothesis
that everything's made of atoms spinning
around i want to ask you what do you
think is the most fascinating aspect of
the physical universe that you've
discovered in your life
that you'd most want to say engrave on a
time capsule uh for other uh
civilizations maybe billions of years
from now when the people that live
around sanjay starr come to visit earth
um
what would you what would you tell them
about what humanity has discovered as of
2021
well i would say
for sure the universe is beautiful i
mean i think it's just
i always
my my
uh
allegorical
walk through the forest where basically
i say you know
doing astronomy in many ways is going
into a new forest which you've never
been in and
you look at all these beautiful trees
and so forth and
wow and they're so big and there's this
there's that and there's
flowers there
red flowers and blue flowers and all of
that so you explore the universe in its
beauty and now comes the physics part
then you discover however after a little
while of studying
and you better be sure to study it well
um that's what towns would have said
then you would find that the blue
flowers happen to be always on the left
side of the road
now that gives you a thought you know
why is that
okay
why would that be and and and then you
develop an idea why that might be then
you go ahead and test it say
and you make more experiment and and and
so so that's that's my view i mean it's
it's
is the beauty part
awesome
and then the next thing is of course you
then zoom into
a few important physical questions
and and and don't get
that's also important of course don't
get completely fascinated only by the
complexity i mean you know then then it
becomes a hodgepodge of uh
you know undigested ideas you have to
you have to get to this point where you
are
picking out the real gems of the of the
wonderful universe
that's delightful okay so we went
billions of years into the future with
that question now we're going to go
maybe 30 40 50 years back in the past
and it's the name of this podcast is
into the impossible because sir arthur c
clarke uh whose name who's the namesake
of the center that i co-direct at uc san
diego he said the only way of
determining the limits of the possible
is to venture beyond them into the
impossible and i want to ask you
reinhardt is there anything that seemed
impossible to you as a 20 year old
perhaps a 30 year old
that because of your courage you found
that it was possible by only going
outside your comfort zone is there
anything that gave you the courage or
advice to your former self that you
would give to a young reinhardt you know
to go into the impossible any advice to
your former soul
yeah well okay i mean again let me come
back to the sports i think that
the sports for me
was a
uniquely preparatory
i didn't know that but i mean that's
certainly i would say it's uniquely
preparatory
pre-exercise to do science because
um
you really sometimes have to bite your
yeah you have to
you know
work extremely hard you have to
stay at it you have to focus
and
the focusing part is i would say
something which i took
from that and that helped me uh to
you know
get sufficiently deep
um
you know some some problems are just of
a type where you
you have to look at it first i mean as i
said we like the forest i mean
people some people i i see
go into the forest
of course
and then they exit again okay
but you have to first study you have to
really work hard to apply it and then
then of course the other thing i said
you have to have a certain
sense of smell
or where the flu blue flowers might be
found and how you check that out
and i guess i was lucky and i had the
right people with me that's that's
that's uh that makes all the difference
well reinhardt gensol uh fellow
colleague here in san diego or in
california rather at least for the time
being would love to get you down here in
san diego if you can ever break yourself
away from the winter time in germany
and don't want to visit your daughter
maybe you come down here and visit me
in san diego i would love to see you in
person again we haven't been in person
since that town symposium in 2005 and
that's too long although we've been
together virtually now a couple of times
reinhardt thank you so much for spending
so much of your time with me and going
into the impossible with my audience
okay thank you
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
[Music]
foreign